We'll start things off here in lesson
one where you'll brain storm ideas for
your app, and
you'll also build a skeleton UI, and
kind of start looking at some APIs and
libraries.
Now, if you are in the iOS
developer nano degree and
you were following along with
the intersperse lessons,
you can skip this lesson and
move on to lesson two.
Because in lesson two, is where were
going to start choosing an idea for
our app, thinking through features,
building through a paper prototype, and
then actually building and
testing our app.
We'll do lots of user testing in
this phase, to help us find bugs and
also make sure that people
want to actually use your app.
Then, in lesson three,
you'll reflect on the process.
And you'll think about those things
that maybe you'd do differently, or
you could do better.
Because as developers,
if we're going to get better,
we have to think about those things
that we're kind of not so great at.
Now, also this course is only
going to teach you to build an app.
We're not going to talk about
monetizing it or building a business.
If you're interested in that,
Udasity has an entrepreneurship
management nanodegree.
Which is a great option,
if you're a budding entrepreneur and
you want to make a business
out of an iPhone app.
There's a link to it in the instructor
notes, if you want to go check that out.
Now as we continue, this is going
to be a wonderfully messy and
creative and awesome, but
sometimes frustrating journey.
And, it's often said that the journey
of a hundred miles begins with
a single step.
So, let's take that step now.